true to our prime ministers great
example of that so back I think it was
in 2015 he announced that half of his
cabinet was going to be women because it
was 2015 or some like muddle-headed
virtue Signori signaling excuse for not
thinking I think only 20% or 25% of the
elected MPs were female so the proper
balance on average would it be 25
percent female 75 percent male what he
should have done was figured out who
what qualities would make for a
competent cabinet minister because it's
actually quite important to have
competent cabinet ministers and then
selected from among his people for
nothing other than competence but he
could virtue signal and then he set up
the most important board let's say of
the entire country on a quasi random
basis Jesus how pathetic he should have
been pilloried by Canadians for that but
we're so clued out and and also in the
situation that you described it's like
if I say well 50% of Trudeau's cabinet
shouldn't have been women it's like oh
you're a misogynist it's like no only
25% of the elected officials were women
now you might say well it would be
better if 50% of that were elected it's
like maybe it would be better but it
didn't happen
so you can't you can't fix it at the top
end it was appalling so it's a hard
argument to make you know because you
need to know that there's more
difference within groups than between
them in order to be able to come up with
a credible argument you know and then so
yeah